[MUSIC]
LINNEA PASEIRO: Hey there.
My name is Linnea Paseiro.
And welcome to Princeton
University.
[MUSIC]
LINNEA PASEIRO: This is
Forbes College, the
dorm where I live.
I thought we'd take
a little tour.
Come on in.
So this is my dorm room.
My roommate and I have decorated
it really well.
We have pictures from
home everywhere.
Here's my roommate, Pew
She's from Thailand, and we met
last year, actually, at
the Forbes barbecue.
We both love to cook,
and we started the
Forbes cooking club.
PUI: Linnea's the baker and
I'm the cook, so we're the
best combination.
LINNEA PASEIRO: One of the
biggest reasons why we chose
the room, actually, is the
view.
Welcome to Forbes
Sunday brunch.
Lots of people from all
over campus come down
to Forbes for this.
There's a chocolate fountain,
baked brie, and always omelets
ready to order.
Here we are in the
lobby of Forbes.
It might look a little bit out
of the ordinary for a college
dorm, but that's because this
used to be a hotel.
[MUSIC]
ROHAN BHARGAVA: Hey, guys.
My name is Rohan Bhargava, and
I'm a sophomore at Princeton
University.
Welcome to Rockefeller
College.
Why don't we go inside and check
out some of the dorms.
Like most of the dorms
in Rockefeller
College, it's a quad.
This is where we hang out, where
we study together, or
just relax and enjoy a movie.
We have two separate bedrooms,
so each of the bedrooms
function as a double.
This is my roommate, Chris.
CHRIS: Hey, guys.
ROHAN BHARGAVA: We have bunk
beds over here and our two
desks, so we can actually work
out there or stay in here if
we want some more quiet.
The best thing about having a
common room and having three
other roommates is that there's
always someone to talk
to, so you're never
really alone.
[MUSIC]
ROHAN BHARGAVA: This
beautiful space is
Rockey-Mathey Library.
It's really convenient because
it's located right in
Rockefeller College, so during
the winters, you don't even
have to step out if you want
to come and study.
This is Rocky's dining hall.
I think it's one of the most
beautiful on campus.
It actually reminds
a lot of people of
Hogwarts from Harry Potter.
[MUSIC]
JESSE YOUNG: Good afternoon,
and welcome to my dorm in
Butler College.
My name is Jesse Young.
I'm a freshman here at Princeton
University from
Elmsford, New York.
This is Adam.
This is my roommate Ariel.
ARIEL: Hi.
JESSE YOUNG: This dorm is full
of triples, and it's substance
free and single sex.
All the guys here are
really close.
We all hang out a lot, so it's
been a really positive
experience for me personally.
We have our three desks.
This is where we all study,
get work done, hang out.
And if you come this way,
I can just take
you into the bedroom.
We have a closet over here, a
nice room with a view.
So now that we've seen the dorm room.
The next part of the tour will
be the library, where I
personally spend a great
deal of my time.
This way.
Waddup, Rishi?
This is a library, so I need to
try and be a little quiet.
There are computers along the
wall, and it's open 24 hours,
which is what I love.
This is Studio 34.
It's actually the only place
that I know of on campus
that's open until 3:30
in the morning.
[KNOCKING]
JESSE YOUNG: Are you there?
There we go.
DANIELA BARTALINI: Hi.
JESSE YOUNG: Hello.
DANIELA BARTALINI: Hi,
my name is Daniela.
I am another freshman here in
Butler College, and I did the
Bridge Year program in
India last year.
JESSE YOUNG: Best friends,
basically.
DANIELA BARTALINI: This
is Jessica and Angela.
On each of the floors, we
have a study, a lounge, and a
kitchen equipped with an oven and refrigerator.
And my room is a quad.
There's a double bedroom over
here, our common room over
here, and in here
is my bedroom.
[MUSIC]
LINNEA PASEIRO: So I
guess that means
the end of our tour.
We just want to say how much we
love living in Forbes and
going to Princeton as well.
So see you guys later.
Bye!